welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is the breakdown of the
trailer for HBO's The Last of Us based
on the two-part game series from Naughty
Dog the first episode premiering on
January 15th the post-apocalyptic
Survival Story following a Smuggler
transporting a girl across the country
who might be Humanity's best hope for a
cure to a fungal infection from clickers
to bloaters and every Spore in between
I'm gonna break down some details you
missed in this trailer and explain why
this series is gonna rock since the plot
of both part one and part two of the
games are really known at this point by
people who played them I'm gonna avoid
plot spoilers so if you haven't played
the games don't worry you'll be able to
watch this video without getting
everything spoiled for you and thanks to
boxu for sponsoring this video more on
their tasty offerings later so let's go
if you don't think there's hope for the
world
seeing the world
keep going for family
okay so the Last of Us centers around
Joel played by Pedro Pascal and Ellie
played by Bella Ramsay AKA Eliana Mormon
from Game of Thrones in a world stricken
with a mutated strain of the parasitic
cordyceps infection game developer Neil
druckman based this on the real world
parasitic cordyceps fungus that affects
ants and other insects spores latching
onto their brains taking control of
their bodies and minds and then
sprouting out of their heads to release
even more spores awesome so to be clear
these are not zombies per se this isn't
really a virus it's really a fungal
infection but the humans it in facts do
act aggressively and bitey and the
fungus can be transferred that way so 20
years into this apocalypse Joel Ellie
and Joel's partner Tess walk through the
overgrown streets of Boston toward the
Massachusetts state house they're going
to meet with a group called The
fireflies which is a rebel militia that
opposes the government quarantine Zone
authorities in this shot Joel hides
behind a display case showing muskets
this is an exhibit for the American
Revolutionary War in Boston's Freedom
Museum and he's hiding from a clicker a
type of infected that is blind but
extremely sensitive to sound and uses
these clicks for echolocation you know
like bats and other site limited animals
and if you listen closely the clicks do
sound like they are wheezing out of an
inverted trachea or something
so you don't know
a tragic Echo the human this once was in
a setting that Echoes the country this
once was and we end this clip with a
flashback of Joel and his daughter Sarah
in the city of Austin Texas burning
behind them which will likely be from
the opening sequence of part one now I
want to say this is meant to be Austin's
6th Street but I might just be thinking
that because dirty sixth already looks
as chaotic on a normal weekend night
series greater Craig Mason I know you
know we're about to that Austin Film
Festival that year did I just force into
this video the fact that I met Craig
Mason and won the Austin Film Festival
pitch contest in 2015. yes yes I did
moving on I'm not family no
cargo
[Music]
why are you so important
Somewhere Out West they're working on a
cure I think what really impressed them
was the fact that I didn't turn into a
monster all right so Joel is
transporting Ellie Westward across the
country to use her blood to try to
develop a cure she claims to have been
infected but while symptoms normally set
in in around two days three weeks later
Ellie's still fine so she might have a
natural immunity they cross this bridge
outside Pittsburgh it's a major location
from the games boats are sunken and
capsized and the Interiors of Pittsburgh
on the show and the post-flooding
services were all inspired by Robert
polidori's photographs that flooded New
Orleans following Hurricane Katrina
moving on she's so much
thank you
ah so Bella Ramsay's transition from
joking around about twitching to
checking herself and Whispering okay
this is Pitch Perfect Ellie from The
Games also her position in that beam of
sunlight one little weed snaking down
toward her a nice reflection of the way
the spores are trying to get to her but
they fall short you can't touch this
I don't want to say it because I'm not
proud of this joke moving on
[Music]
I'll take you with me
say what I said
you got any advice on the best way west
yeah go east so the music in this
trailer is aha's Take On Me a reference
to The Last of Us Part Two it's a song
that Ellie plays an acoustic cover-up of
her partner Dina after throughout part
one Joel had promised her he was going
to teach her how to play the guitar I
don't want to spoil too much about what
happens but this is deeply significant
we're all gonna cry when this happens
okay in this shot Ellie crosses a plane
called Joel tends to an injured test on
the rooftop behind them is the clock
tower of the Marriott Boston customs
house it's one of the city's first
skyscrapers Joel and Ellie joined the
brothers Henry and Sam in Pittsburgh
this location with the kids painting all
over the walls looks like the entrance
to isha's sewer hideout in the game then
Joel and Ellie hide behind this car as a
Humvee with militia paint storms pass we
also see some shots of trucks containing
armed militiamen painted with we the
people but this Nissan has a Kansas
license plate that's because they shot
many of the Pittsburgh scenes in Kansas
City on the Kansas side and with that wi
in the corner of the plate that stands
for wyando County now there's a lot of
things I would miss about my day-to-day
life if you know all of a sudden there
was a you know a parasitic fungus
dystopian thing going on in society but
one of the things I would miss most is
my snacks I love snacks and baksu is my
favorite Japanese snack subscription box
they work with family businesses all
across Japan to deliver a new theme of
authentic treats every month your first
box will be Seasons of Japan and then
after that you will get a new monthly
theme just like this one this month's
theme is Hokkaido Wonderland which
showcases traditional winter flavors
from Japan's northernmost Island all
right what are we going to try here I'm
going to eat these white grape gummies
from Hokkaido
yeah oh I love a good squishy squish
it's nice and soft on my nice and soft
tea I could eat a million of these
things and you know what the nice thing
about baksu is that when you really fall
in love with a snack you can stock up on
your favorites through baksu Boutique
both I and the new Rockstar's office
have been receiving these boxes for ages
and we love them boxu makes a really
great gift for the travel lover in your
life or really for any person who
appreciates good food if you give baksu
as a present you get to give someone you
love a fun and unique food experience
and support our Channel at the same time
it's really a win-win so click the link
in the description and use the code
rockstars to get 15 off your order I'm
just really looking forward to the
series as a portrait of the North
American West and I say North America
not American West because they didn't
shoot much of this in Alberta Canada
sorry people from Colorado and Utah and
Wyoming but hey we got actor Graham
Greene known for roles from Dances with
Wolves and Wind River plays Marlin an
original character to the series who
lives with his wife Lawrence in the
Wyoming Wilderness we see Joel sneaking
in past his fence with Ephedra sign
Federal Disaster Response agency based
on the real world FEMA but in the world
of the last of us bedra has essentially
become the ruling government Authority
Joel is a Smuggler so he sneaks in and
out of the federal quarantine zones all
the time moving on
you've come this far
and you know what's out there
you're not gonna scare us
scared who
Joel looks up to see the aurora borealis
and then this creepy shot showing him
climbing a staircase past a whole
freaking pile of infected bodies that
has grown into a heap of dried and
rotted fungal Mass but this is what ants
do to other ants affected with cordyceps
fungus they carry them away from the
colony and just pile them up so that
those spores don't infect the rest of
the ants in the colony ah moving on
[Music]
than any of us could have ever imagined
be careful who you put your faith in
okay looks like Joel and Elli are being
surrounded by David's group in Utah we
also see Marlene that's Merle
dandridge's character leader of the
fireflies group a flashback shows
Ellie's birth and hey her mother is
played by Ashley Johnson who played
Ellie in the games actually Troy Baker
who played Joel in the games cameos as
one of the hunters in David's group
Ellie hangs out a shopping mall this is
likely Boston's Liberty Garden Mall and
here she hangs out with Riley played by
storm Reed this is coming from the Left
Behind DLC that shows Ellie before she
met Joel actually the photo booth here
is likely the photo booth that created
that photo of Ellie and Riley in that
left behind cover then we meet Frank and
Bill played by Murray Bartlett and Nick
Offerman these two are survivalists who
live in Lincoln Massachusetts they
fortified this city into a booby trap
death trap and then a shot of Henry and
Sam hugging praise yourself the series
is gonna break your heart moving on
be her father she was someone's
trust me
okay we get some shots from within a
vehicle here this Burning house might be
Joel's daughter Sarah's point of view as
Tommy drives them out of the Austin
suburb from the part one opening they do
pass Lewis's Farm in that part so this
could be that there's also an explosion
as they drive down on Austin Street
maybe the gas station that they pass
that a car runs into and blows up then a
quick shot of David chopping a butcher
Cleaver beside Ellie's head David who
leads that group in Utah it's gonna be a
major antagonist in this first season
and then after the title we move on to
the last bit
okay this big boy is the bloater one of
the strongest infected creatures in the
game whose fungal outgrowth is so thick
that it covers the body like armor so
you can shoot and shoot and shoot and
hit him with a baseball bat light him on
fire it's gonna take forever to take him
down because it's all just like flesh
and he keeps going I also just love how
a few Runners Are Climbing up alongside
him with a fire behind a terrifying
image here now in the game you do fight
one of these in Lincoln you find another
one in the hotel basement in Pittsburgh
and the sound design of this thing is
incredible it's a deep guttural growl
emitting from a mouth that you'll notice
is a bit larger than the creepy little
orifice that the bloater has in the game
in the game it's applied that the fungal
outgrowth hasn't really changed the
human mouth beneath it which just gives
it a creepy Humanity but here it looks
like it completely stretched out his jaw
which is also just terrifying in a
different way I'm so so excited for the
series it's gonna be heartbreaking it's
gonna be realistic and gritty with an
amazing cast with amazing landscape
imagery and sound design and music I
can't wait for new rock stars to break
it down in the New Year let me know your
thoughts on this trailer follow with me
on Tick Tock Hive Instagram and Twitter
at EA boss follow new Rockstar subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]